welcome back to New rockstars I'm Winnie
van laningham and during the big Rihanna
concert last Sunday night we got to see
a new look at Indiana Jones in the dial
of Destiny in one of the ad spots
although the clip was brief there's
still a ton of new info to speculate on
so today I'm taking you frame by frame
through the Super Bowl's Indy 5 dial of
Destiny trailer the trailer opens with
Indiana Jones standing next to Toby
Jones's basil beneath the darkened
warplane riddled sky from another scene
in the extended trailer that dropped
back in December we know that this
moment likely takes place either before
or after the scene where Indian basil
find themselves in a fight on top of a
moving train Indy 5 takes place during
the Cold War which if you remember from
11th grade history class was the period
of geopolitical tension between the
United States the Soviet Union and their
respective allies that took place
shortly after World War II ended in
1945. the struggle for dominance between
the U.S and the Soviet Union was battled
via indirect means like psychological
warfare propaganda Espionage and of
course the space race in 1959 the Soviet
Union's lunatu spacecraft became the
very first first human-made object to
land on the moon and the space race was
on the US's Apollo 11 team walked on the
moon a decade later in 1969 setting Indy
five in 1969 gives us the prime timeline
to explore one of the darker aspects of
the United States moon landing a German
scientist acquired by the U.S after
World War II named Werner Von Braun was
largely the face of the American space
program but he was also a former Nazi
who spent his time building rockets and
missiles for Hitler before they lost the
war this dude has a lot of blood on his
hands and for a long time America
basically whitewashed his contributions
to Nazism because of his spectacular
technological advancements it turns out
the dial of Destiny will explore a
fictionalized version of Von Braun's
complicated Legacy in Matt Mickelson's
character Jurgen baller the movie's
co-writer Jazz buzzworth told Empire
that quote the simple fact is that the
moon landing program was run by a bunch
of ex-nazis how exit they are is the
question in this next clip we learned
that ballerin Jones actually have
history together using a combo of sweet
sweet deep fake technology and old
footage from past indie films we flash
back to that fateful night in 1944 when
Indy first punched that smug Nazi right
in the kisser Indiana Jones using its
hat to obscure the incoming punch is
possibly a move he learned from Salah we
saw Salah use this technique with a
newspaper to much success in the Last
Crusade in that same interview with
Empire mads Mickelson teased his
character's motivations saying quote
he's a man who would like to correct
some of the mistakes of the past there's
something that could make the world a
much better place to live in he would
love to get his hands on it Indiana
Jones wants to get his hands on it as
well the parade that Indy rides through
on Horseback is the ticker tape parade
in New York City thrown in honor of
Apollo 11 on August 13 1969. three weeks
after Neil Armstrong Buzz Aldrin and
Michael Collins first ventured to the
Moon as he races after Boyd holbrook's
character clabber or clay bar or clubbar
I don't know how to pronounce his name
Just go with it you can see a banner in
the background that reads giant leap for
mankind Apollo 11 with what looks like a
replica of the vessel's Command Module
in the first trailer we also saw Dr
Jones Show his students an image of the
Command Module in class but in fact this
particular ticker tape parade holds the
record for the highest tonnage of
celebratory paper products and a lot of
things baby hungry sweaty curious about
what it means to be a tree but you know
what I'm not tired because I've got sand
land sandland's products focus on
restoring the body's natural sleep
Rhythm and a sustainable clean and
non-habit-forming way there's a lot of
sleep aids that just knock you out but
those don't actually help you wake up
rested or train your body to naturally
sleep again the great thing about sand
land is that they help break the
patterns of stress and anxiety before
sleep so that you eventually won't need
any sleep aids including samblan
sandland focuses on the two key stages
of sleep struggle falling asleep at the
beginning of the night and staying
asleep throughout the night which is why
we've got fall asleep plus and stay
asleep plus both supplements are made
from a safe but highly effective formula
nation of l-theanine magnesium citrate
valerian root and CBN CBN is the
ingredient in a hemp plant that has been
indicated to assist the body with
sleeping naturally it's
non-habit-forming and effective you just
take a tablet or two stay asleep an hour
before bed with a glass of water in
about 15 minutes before you want to fall
asleep do one or two fall asleep tablets
and let them dissolve in your mouth
before swallowing after a couple of
weeks you'll have reset your body's
sleep program and then you can be the
Pepi one at your office thanks so much
to sandland for sponsoring this video
click the link in the description and
use promo code new rockstars to get 15
off your sandland purchase but Nazis on
the moon are only one of Dr Jones's
concerns this time around director James
Mangold told Entertainment Weekly that
Indy's goddaughter Helena is a catalyst
for the film although she claims in this
clip that she's here to rescue Indy it
seems like they both could use a little
rescuing Helena's gotten herself in a
bit of trouble and brings that to Indy's
doorstep she's a character who's a
wonderful set of contradictions charming
and Brilliant but also a lot of trouble
if it wasn't obvious by the way these
two or leaping between cars and out of
flaming airplanes we can expect to see
Helena give Indy's adventurousness a run
for his money the plane we see them jump
out of is some kind of German bomber you
can see the black crosses on the wings
when they plummet to a Coastal Island
below the island could be where German
scientists are conducting their rocket
experiments and indy could have hitched
a ride on one of their bombers to thwart
them now there was a popular fan theory
that Helena would be revealed to be the
daughter of Marcus Brody but mangle jot
that theory down as well saying that
she's a daughter of a friend of Indies
who we will also meet in the movie
Personally I'm most excited to see The
Return of salt like kalena we can expect
to see his character help bring Dr Jones
out of retirement much to Indy's
momentary Chagrin interestingly when we
see this clip of Indy walking towards
the train behind Saul's voiceover he
soldiers atopeter waving a UK flag it's
hard to tell based on their Silhouettes
if this scene takes place around the
same time as the other train scenes from
1944 but it's possible that this is the
train where Jones fights valer as well
lastly we gotta speculate on that
McGuffin Raiders of the Lost Ark brought
us one of the most famous macguffins in
film history with the Ark of the
Covenant and now we've got the dial of
Destiny we know that valer wants it for
the moon Nazis but what's it used for
exactly because of all the time jumping
elements hinted at in Indy five I'm
wondering if it could be a time dial
allowing its user to access the pass to
fuel future space Tech Dr Jones might
not believe in magic after all the
adventures he's been on but clearly the
Nazis do and he might have to suspend
his disbelief in the Supernatural once
again to defeat them if you want to see
Eric and I absolutely lose our [__] over
the dial of Destiny trailer check out
our previous breakdown and reaction also
you gotta check out Eric's new channel
the Deep dive it's launching on February
17th and you don't want to miss it
you're about to get hit with some pure
and adulterated bus baby follow me on
Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
foreign